en 2003 cent cinquante mille soldats
américains sont déployés sur le
territoire irakien
une date qui marque le début de la
guerre d'irak et la chute du président
saddam hussein le président américain
george w.bush décide d'envoyer des
milliers de soldats supplémentaires en
irak
les effectifs militaires américains
atteignent 165 mille j'y aille sur le
sol irakien
en 2008 la barre des 4000 militaires
américains tués en irak est atteinte les
manifestations anti guerre se
multiplient partout aux états unis la
maison blanche annonce le retrait de
8000 soldats d'irak
dans le même temps 4500 militaires
américains sont déployés en afghanistan
barack obama hostiles à la guerre en
irak promet de retirer la majorité de
ses soldats d'ici le courant de l'année
2010 le départ annoncé de l'armée
américaine coïncide avec le début d'une
importante crise politique en irak
suite à la prise de contrôle d'agbar
plusieurs régions d'irak les états unis
s'impliquent de nouveau militairement
plusieurs soldats sont déployés pour
bombarder les positions dédia liste à la
suite d'un bombardement américain contre
une coalition paramilitaires chiite des
milliers d'irakiens s'en prennent à
l'ambassade des états unis située à
bagdad le général iranien qassem
suleimani et l'irakien abou mehdi al -10
chef-adjoint du hhk by meurent suite à
une frappe de drone américain à bagdad
dans la foulée le parlement irakiens
votent en faveur de l'expulsion des
troupes étrangères d'irak
washington et bagdad annonce dans un
communiqué que les états unis
poursuivraient le retrait de leurs
forces en irak
donald trump accueille le nouveau
premier ministre irakien à la maison
blanche pour évoquer ce départ